all right well you remember that
remember the movie swingers with Vince
Vaughn and John Favreau and toward the
end he's all drunk in that bar at the
diner and he gets up and he gets on the
table and he's swinging because you're
all grown's up and you're all grown's up
well guess what I think crypto is all
grown up
because crypto exchange coinbase now has
approval to offer crypto Futures Trading
to its customers the green light comes
nearly two years after coinbase filed
the initial application company says it
hopes to make crypto Futures available
in the coming weeks shares of coinbase
closing slightly in the red today
unclear why but it's a big deal let's
talk more about what it might mean
bringing crypto Guru and Tech investor
Anthony pompliano I guess I guess crypto
where the future does feel like it's all
growns up
Brian listen I I think that uh Bitcoin
in the crypto industry is not going
anywhere uh I used to come on this show
five years ago and as the price crashed
from 20 000 down to three thousand
dollars I told everyone that uh this is
a very very resilient industry young
people want these assets and they're
going to continue to buy it and uh it
would recover I think we're in the exact
same situation we've obviously seen the
price crash significantly we're about 50
down from all-time Highs but I think
that what we are seeing underlying here
something like this uh Futures
development with coinbase but also a lot
of the trading volume across the
industry is showing that this stuff is
not going to go away and so people who
have gotten bored or have left I think
they're in for a big surprise over the
next 18 to 24 months as this thing comes
roaring back once again
roaring back and listen if you're a
long-term crypto investor I know you are
I'm talking about you the pejorative you
know the rhetorical out there and across
the world you've been through 50
declines before right and if you've
stomached it you've gotten Rich what do
you see as the next sort of bull
Catalyst for crypto Anthony
most people watching this show they went
to economics 101 class and when they sat
there one of the first things they were
taught was supply and demand when you
look at Bitcoin about 19 million of the
21 million Bitcoin are sitting out there
in the circulating supply of that a
majority are being held for over one
year without trading hands so it's a
highly illiquid uh circulating Supply
and so when you look at things like the
having that's coming up next year it's a
supply shock to an asset that usually
leads to more media coverage that media
coverage then leads to more
institutional participation you add in
things like BlackRock coming in with
their ETF applications also others like
Arc invest Etc and then you even look at
things like these Futures right Futures
make up about 80 percent of all trading
volume in the crypto industry there's
over a trillion dollars worth of that
trading volume every single year if you
look at something like there's a new
data platform called Velo data that goes
and highlights a lot of this stuff you
can see the volumes are trading uh and
people are not leaving so the mainstream
conversation has changed but if you just
look at supply and demand highly
illiquid market and you're going to get
these catalysts to the upside so when
that happens we've seen it over and over
again I expect that there will be a much
higher bitcoin price in the coming
months yeah it feels like the True
Believers they're sticking around maybe
some of the Fringe players they've gone
away but this another big step in crypto
Anthony to appreciate it we'll see you
soon thank you